Kathy O'Neal is director of the lead
program in data practices at Columbia
University Graduate School of Journalism
and she's employed as data science
consultant at Johnson's Johnson research
labs she attended UC Berkeley as an
undergraduate earned a PhD in
mathematics from Harvard and afterward
held positions in mathematics
departments of MIT and Barnard College
doing research in arithmetic algebraic
geometry yes she's co-author of the book
that was mentioned today already doing
data science straight talk from the
front line and also very importantly
she's author of one of my personal
favorite blogs math babe org and if you
don't look at it you should and here's
Kathy thinks oh my god I don't know
about you people but I hate this room
because i can't see people around here
and I mean I love the organizers don't
get me wrong but the room isn't very
good for interaction i'm a very
interactive person so please feel free
to come sit at this chair over here or
close by or or motion to me because I
don't like speaking by myself over here
I'm feeling lonely already don't make me
cry okay so i worked in arithmetic
algebraic geometry that was really pure
mathematics and then in 2006 for some
ridiculous reason which i might go into
and you can ask me to go into i decided
to become a quant at a hedge fund
exactly right before the credit crisis
so I entered and got a front-row seat at
the dysfunction that was our financial
system from 2007 to 2011 and then I left
in disgust but I by the way just want to
say i loved the data oh my god i fell in
love with data it's very sexy I loved
the analysis I loved feeling like I was
learning stuff I didn't love other
aspects of Finance I'll bring it bring
them up a little bit later because I do
think we have lessons to learn from
finance another thing i want to mention
is that I think data science big date
we've all complained about the rhetoric
I'll do I'll do the same um kind of
started in finance not really it started
in a lot of different places but when
people talk about big data and data
science I think well-financed was the
first data science and other people
might say no astrophysics was the first
data science and I would say well you
know a lot of astrophysicists became
quants on had you know a hedge funds on
Wall Street there was basically no data
science there was no analysis really of
data on Wall Street until like the
black-scholes and stuff and like 70s in
the 80s in the bond market so and then
all these scientists came to Wall Street
and they started trying out different
things from their different fields and
so it was like the first I guess what
I'm saying is the first
interdisciplinary data-oriented science
happened on Wall Street so that's one of
the reasons i'm going to say we can
learn lessons from finance because that
failed spectacularly in certain ways in
other ways it didn't so after that I
left I went to I decided to like do
something good for the world so I went
and worked as a data scientist it took
as much work as rewriting the my title
on my resume to get a job in an
advertising startup tech company in New
York City where I was analyzing the
propensity to click on ads for people
who you know had max versus PCs and by
the way people of max have more money
did anyone know that so after a few
months of working in data science I was
like holy crap this stuff is really
interesting and also kind of alarming in
various ways so I got kind of into
thinking about it in a meta way rather
than just doing my job I wanted to think
like what is this is this a thing to
what extent is it a thing can we define
it that's where I wrote that book doing
data science it was an effort to try to
describe the thing that is data science
and whether it deserves its own field my
conclusion is that it does we can argue
about that and then I started also being
kind of just like a skeptic a data
skeptic
which is actually hard a hard road to
walk down if you work in New York City
around a lots lots and lots and lots of
venture capital funding so we'll talk
about that a little bit but just to make
the point that there's there's a lot of
kool-aid being drunk around there so
guess who likes skeptics journalists
journalists are actually kind of Awesome
in that way they might actually go
overboard and like negative news more
than they should but one thing that was
cool about recently being hired by the
journalism school of Columbia to start a
data journalism program is that they
were like totally embracing my
skepticism for the first time so that
was kind of nice so that was what I did
this summer I was the program director
for a data journalism program that
turned journalists into data journalists
that was the attempt anyway and I think
we did a pretty good job we had some
amazing projects we taught them Python
we taught them how to do data scraping
we taught them how to manipulate data
with taught them how to use algorithms
we did everything on the ec2 Amazon
Cloud we had instances out there we made
them bigger when we had bigger data so
the way I tell my husband that the
summer went was the first half of the
summer we taught them to think of
themselves as God's because they came in
thinking that anyone who could do data
analysis was a god and the second half
of the summer we taught them that they
weren't God's because the second half of
the summer we focused and said on skills
we focused on other kinds of literacy so
I think of this functional literacy is
like skills like can you do Python can
you write a code will it work will you
get an answer can you clean code can you
put things in pandas data frames the
second half of the summer we thought
about well what else could you have done
and how would that have changed the
result and we talked about to what
extent are the default settings on Excel
forcing you to think in a certain way
that was um it was a really great
experience and I was happy to sort of
not only teach a group of young
bright-eyed bushy-tailed journalists how
to how to do stuff but had a
think about stuff and so that's one of
the reasons I'm here because I think
that's an important part so I was asked
to come pitch a gale data science
institute that's what I'm going to do
and i'm also going to actually tell i'm
first going to tell you why I think you
should have one although you already
might know but I'm going to tell you why
I think you should have 1 i'm going to
be very passionate about it because
that's what i do and then i'm going to
tell you like the ticky tack details of
stuff because i interviewed a couple
people over at it see at columbia
institute for data science and
engineering which has had ups and downs
it was announced to exist by bloomberg i
want to say three years ago but it's
something like two years ago and it's
it's taken a while and we'll talk about
why that happened so why okay here's the
thing when I went into the hedge fund it
was like really really intense and
proprietary and I wasn't allowed to talk
to anyone including my own office mate
about what I was working on I was
working with larry summers on some
projects i'll tell you guys now but not
after the top just kidding uh but we had
one thing we did have in our group which
was the futures group was like this kind
of sweet lease M&R on on ways of
thinking about modeling run by my boss
Steve strong who is really really a very
good modeler and he was a bayesian so we
talked about prior beliefs and what were
our priors and just like the young woman
who talked about the UM an epi score or
a post or whatever it was she talked
about down waiting data that you are
less certain of we did that we also down
weighted data that was old that the
extent to which we down weighted data on
you know what was the half life of a
piece of data like if it's a week old is
it old news or it does it depend on the
market is it different in bonds than it
is in commodity so that kind of thing
that's the kind of conversation we'd
have and we called that lambda often
when we were down waiting all data we
had this kind
of where we didn't even take averages of
things we took you know average is
weighted by the the sort of down waiting
lambda variable so that was called our
book you know lambda and it was
considered our belief in how much we
lost interest in in the data as it got
older as it became less certain this is
called the prior this is called I
actually should have said I should have
said the overburdened lambda because
what I'm going to do here as I'm going
to demonstrate that I then went into
data science and I found two other ways
of imagining the same parameter called
lambda in a totally different context
but it was exactly the same thing it was
lambda it was even called lambda so
there there was some kind of like
magical undercurrent of understanding
that this is all the same thing but I
found in machine learning that people
did I think it was called Ridge
regression and then there's another
maybe a different part of computer
science that they did they did L to
regression okay those both had lambdas
and I don't member which one is which um
but they were there were two different
names for the same thing and it was it
ended up being in exactly the same usage
as I would have used my belief lambda in
a regression in just a simple
multivariate regression but it was
caught up in a totally different way so
so he was thought of for the most part
so I'm going to skip ahead in in one for
one slide for a moment and thought that
you would use it as a insurance that
your algorithm would converge so you had
some kind of you had some kind of I
think of it geometrically because i'm an
admin geometers we have some kind of
space and you're using some kind of
newton algorithm to try to find some
minimum and you're like you know you're
going to find the minimum but is it a
global minimum or is it a local minimum
and you're like well if you tuned lambda
lambda is high enough then it's forced
to be convex and then it's a global
minimum so whatever I just said what I
mean to say is lambda was used the same
lambda used as a way of ensuring that
your algorithm would finish called the
convergence insurance i call it
then at this the some of the same people
would turn around and they would say
well that's that's how we know we have
convergence but actually we use lambda
to tune to optimize our algorithm so we
we sort of tests our algorithm four
different lambdas and we see which one
gives us the most accurate result and
that's our lambda so it's actually a
piper parameter that people use to tune
their algorithms to optimize it for the
results does that make sense same lambda
now I just want to make the point that
this lambda which was being tuned to
optimize your results was definitely not
the same lambda we used at least in
theory to sort of state our belief
because you know when you state your
belief you're not supposed to tune it
afterwards um so I thought that was
pretty interesting because I'm like well
this is it's always called lambda but
it's it's really literally meaning three
different things to three different
fields coming into this into this
mishmash of space called data science
and I think we can learn from each other
so another example I came to and I call
these technical overlaps this is the
last one I'm sure of it's a technical
overlap and it's an interesting one and
it's overburdening ones poor little
Greek letter but the second one I'm not
really sure of but it's so fascinating
to me I was doing a talk I went to
Berkeley to give of talk I math
colloquium and I gave a talk about
recommendation engines because they were
like well can you talk about something
from data science because everyone in
math wants to learn data science so I
was like okay i'll talk about
recommendation engines and one of the
things i wrote about in my book is i
don't know if you guys heard the about
hunch com it's kind of a fun story you
go to hunch com and they and you get
asked 20 yes or no questions and at the
end of 20 questions they know everything
about you and it's like really really
depressing because it means we only have
20 dimensions of interestingness like
you know basically chick flick or dick
flick you know like basically this were
the first one are you a man or a woman
that and then it gets like less
interesting from there but then but they
that's defines you pretty much pretty
much accurately
after that they tell you what kind of
ipad you want or whatever they tell you
what phone you want and they're right
it's really frustrating so that's a
recommendation engine that I learned
about using alternating least squares
it's called the latent factor model and
then I was like looking around for other
recommendation engines to show the
mathematicians in Berkeley and someone
from Spotify who's a friend of mine told
me oh you should use the ones we use
they come from this paper from google
that Google News if you guys know what
google news is everyone is a google news
is but i think anybody uses it anymore
but anyway so they actually used there's
two there's a couple it's a really great
paper actually beautiful but one of the
things they use is a latent topic model
the other thing is a co visitation model
which is also very sexy as a model uses
min hash um but anyway going over to the
latent topic model that so the layton
factor model let me start at the late in
fact or the first one requires you
understand the sort of eigen values
eigen spaces of love matrices you sort
of the rank you sort of sort the
eigenvalues and in terms of size and you
take the biggest ones and those are the
most important ones in terms of your
variance and so it basically depends on
a factorization of matrices so but then
at the end of the day you choose a
number of a number of dimensions that
you actually give it about and if your
hunch com it's 20 and then you're like I
give a [ __ ] about 20 things and then I
can infer the rest okay so the first 20
dimensions of human nature are important
than everything else is trivial he's
just idiosyncratic i should say um then
okay so then i looked into this paper
and I thought I understood the late in
factor model pretty well I looked into
this paper i found the latent topic
model which was had some technical name
pls i which you can look up and it was
based on a statistical model with
various assumptions about distributions
and stuff but at the end of the day you
chose 20 i chose a number could be 20
and then you did and then you had the
same
number of variables as you had in the
late and factor model you I could even
tell you how many variables like
basically two very elongated rectangular
matrices of size 20 and the number of
people involved or 20 and the number of
items involved so in the case with
Spotify you're the items are songs and
the people are people and Layton topic
model the items are news articles that
you may not have read you may have read
and the people are people so you have
these two really long matrices and the
choice of 20 and you have some
arithmetic to update this when you get
new data so in in like that they were
presented in very different ways they
were optimizing two very different
looking things one of the most
applicable of them was additive but at
the end of the day I was like you know
what I think these are the same
algorithm I just think that if you if
you make specific choices for for this
distribution like Gaussian or whatever I
think this will come down to the very
same algorithm and when I gave this talk
in berkeley i just asked the audience is
this the same algorithm or not and some
guy who's a fifth year graduate student
of statistics is like yeah that's the
same algorithm and it gave me a
reference but i couldn't understand it
so i'm not really sure it's true but
here's my point my point is it's
probably true or if it's not exactly the
same algorithm it's really close and
it's coming from machine learning on the
latent factor model or even mathematics
I'm not exactly sure versus statistics
pure up up in straight straight up
statistics and it's like we should know
this we have these really large
companies depending on these algorithms
that are essentially the same thing or
or or if they're not it's an interesting
fact that we should be talking about
which no one is talking about ok so I'm
guess I'm what I'm saying is that there
is technical overlap in at least in
industry and I'm sure in academics as
well that uses different language that
uses different even different
assumptions but but they're the same
technical thing and the fact that they
came people came upon them in totally
different ways is what makes them
interesting
ok now I'm going to tell you why we
could never do this we can never get
scared ok it's never going to happen
I'll explain why so I spent as I told
you the summer working in journalism at
the journalism school and I was doing
like a data journalism program for
journalists and I was constantly talking
to the computer science department
because many of my students are now
taking computer science classes and
basically and I'm not going to this is
an exaggeration and I apologize to
anyone who gets offended by this but
everyone a journalism hated me and
everyone in the computer science
department hated me and I'm cool with
that because I've got a thick skin but
there is a clash of cultures and it's
real so let me explain what I mean
journalism and i'm just i'm going to
it's cartoonish what I'm saying ok but
just just there's an element of truth to
what I'm about to say and again not
saying it to a fun i'm saying it to
clarify but journalists care about the
human story human face on the story what
is who is that person that caused the
victim if it's there's no victim there's
no story and that's not always true but
in traditional journalism it often is
true they think of the data person
generally speaking as a service person
somebody who like does the infographic
and like gets paid by the hour in
computer science you have the
complimentary blind spot where you have
people who are focused on fast efficient
algorithms large-scale you have it's
very macho I'm you have to really
understand like you know web protocols
to even get coffee in the lounge um and
that they're just like why human messy
stories individual stories why who care
is not relevant so what I'm saying is
like to try to to try to bring together
even those two departments for the sake
of this emerging field of data
journalism it's not easy but at the same
time but so this is my obstacle slide so
I don't have to I don't have to give you
the good news yet
um let me give you another example
though and this goes to a woman named
noemi alidad who's in bioinformatics at
Columbia and is also heading the health
center at the Institute for data science
and engineering Columbia so I
interviewed her because now I have
journalistic approaches to everything
which is fun so I interviewed her this
week about this talk and I said so how's
it going it sees three years old how are
things and she was like well things are
looking up but at the beginning was
really hard because there was this
culture clash between bio informatics
and computer science and those look will
tell me about it and I don't want to
make the cs guys bad guys by the way I
love computer scientists my parents are
both computer scientists but she was
basically said a similar kind of thing
she said you know the computer
scientists are like well you know at the
beginning not anymore at the beginning
the computer scientists approach was we
don't need to know the health stuff the
medicine we know how to mine data just
give us the data stop talking to us just
give it to us we will do it and we will
solve medicine and then the people in
medicine were like these guys don't know
anything about the contacts they don't
understand missing values they don't
understand the bias they don't
understand the diff between this
population in that population and I
already know how to do my analysis leave
me alone so we have the same kind of
complimentary blind spot in the cultures
and complementary values so it's a real
thing and that's within academia so if
if you want it and I don't want to just
have a data science institute at Yale
for just academics like theoretically
ideally it would include people from
industry and it would include people
from government who are doing civic data
stuff and with open date and all that
stuff and we've heard that from them
today as well and we have that same
problem there is that you have this
complete you have the blind spots and
you do value different things and and I
don't I don't mean like I get paid for
this I don't get paid for that I that's
the next slide this slide I mean you
actually dismiss the other person's
expertise so part of
a data science institute is creating a
community where you talk enough about
what you're actually the actual problems
of your analysis are until you have
respect for that person's expertise
because it is a question of respect and
by the way just to give away the ending
of that story with an ome she told me
that in the last year and a half people
have been writing large grants together
from the Medical School in the
engineering school and that through the
grant writing process and sometimes they
got the grant sometimes they didn't but
when they got the grants especially
starting to actually work together on
these large scale projects have given
them an immense amount of mutual respect
so those initial problems are fading
away so they can be overcome however I
mean that doesn't keep me from having a
second slide of obstacles and by the way
again raise your hands if you disagree
with me or want to add something because
I like interaction um I just want to
make the point that I've been an
academic so I know what the problem the
actual limitations of an everyday life
as an academic art and that you're
you're incentivized to think on a daily
a daily basis of publishing papers and
getting funded whereas if you're a
policymaker you might or yep somebody in
government you're you're actually trying
to affect policy so I work to the I work
to the mayor's office under Bloomberg
for six months and Health and Human
Services working with homeless data so i
can talk about that but like it's a very
different approach to what you decide to
talk about or what you avoid talking
about i think it's a better way of
approaching that too is when you're in
an inn when you're working and
proprietary startup land which I did for
a few years sometimes it's a marketing
technique you do it sometimes you are
literally just the quant in the corner
as you know hey we got quants their PhDs
or there sometime so sometimes you just
have to exist and that's that's that's
not really data science but other times
when you do do actual data science what
leaks out is is more about PR then then
really about science
and sometimes you actually are trying to
inform the public and we saw an example
of that again with environmental score
which was great but I just want to make
the point that all the people that I
wish would come and be part of the data
science institute at Yale or whatever
you call it they all have different
metrics of success so it's it would
you'd have to find a way through you
know however it gets funded or however
people get brownie points or however
people get what they want you have to
figure out a way for everyone to have a
reason to be there and and of course
part of it would be that they learned
how to do better science so here's the
thing the really urgent reason we need
this is because there is no nobody doing
it quite like you could do it here you
guys have a Yale Law School which is an
incredible place they already have
something called the internet and
society Center so they're already
talking about ethics and standards for
date for for doing data in an industry
but it could be a wider discussion as
well we have an incredible amount of
complexity going on it's it's almost
impossible for non data experts to
understand what's actually happening in
Google or Facebook and it affects policy
so I went to a I went to a house
subcommittee meeting on big data and
analytics about a year ago and I was
really unimpressed with the people that
were talking there and their their
approach to explaining how big data was
important and how everybody doesn't mind
their privacy violations and it was
staffed by the head of research at IBM
and other industry representatives so it
was it's just a lopsided discussion here
i'm not saying those people don't
deserve to talk i'm just saying that
well the policymakers are hearing is
incredibly biased towards commercial
interests and that doesn't have to be
true um
I'll just say that again commercial
interests this man said that privacy is
dead and like he shouldn't have the last
word on that he has too much money
coming in to think otherwise so we
should have some people thinking about
data in a critical way that don't get
rich off of it don't get rich off of
obscuring what's actually going on I
also wanted to move if I'm not radical
enough yet let me just say um I really
think we could take some lessons from
the financial crisis the way I look at
the financial crisis as i said the
finance was the was big data was data
science before before data science was a
term and one of the things they made up
there's a lot of ways you can think
about the financial crisis but one way
you can think about it is that it was a
siloed mistake that we had different
characters who were aware or semi aware
of bad things happening in the mortgage
market what we in particular well but
not nobody was aware of everything
that's one of the problems unless less
there were people who were everything in
in case in which case those people but
most people were just aware that what
they were doing locally was kind of
sketchy but they were making a lot of
money off of it and they didn't they
didn't think they didn't have to think
in a more global sense so it was a
question of siloed information in a
particular and the most massive silo was
between fine and wall street and the
regulators and that's a mistake i think
that cost the the people of this the
taxpayers that the people who lost their
homes etc that was a is it that was the
repercussions for that so I guess what
I'm saying is I think what we can do
when it comes to big data data science
is we can make better science but we can
also make sure that we are not like
screwing the average person with the big
data models that we already have by
keeping in touch with who's actually
working on the data and keeping in touch
with regulators and policymakers about
what that actually looks like and what
the real risks are and i have seen
progress on this front one of the most
impressive things I've seen lately is
Obama's Big Data Report
with Podesta who went around the country
and talked to people about various civil
rights violations that are potentially
happening with big data so great to see
that but it's like just one report and
we should have an institute devoted to
that or not only to that but that should
be one of the things that so where is
that conversation going to happen I mean
that's another way of looking at it it's
not going to happen at facebook facebook
is spending millions of dollars lobbying
against the European privacy laws it's
not going to happen it's going to happen
in an institution but it has to be an
institution that has enough actual
information about the way data is use
that they can have an informed
discussion so I feel like an institute
may be in the center to the law center
but maybe here I mean maybe at the Yale
data Institute could invite policymakers
well get I'll get to that in a second so
what would a data science institute look
like so what are the I'm kind of a party
planner so the first thing I think about
is parties with wine but we can have a
colloquium first um it has to be a
community as what I'm saying you it's
the way you get people to figure out I
use lambda for tuning parameter oh I use
a lambda for that you know the way you
do that is you get people to talk to
each other and the way you get two
people to talk to each other is you you
get them together in the same physical
location and you talk about your
research and you also you also share
food and wine and you promote
cross-disciplinary research with support
from grants from you know we've seen
today a lot of a lot of potential
support for this kind of thing so that's
awesome you need to place a space to
work in so the Columbia it C has like
they're building out space in the north
west corner of this of campus right now
they dont have space so it's not
absolutely critical if as long as you
get to like rent rooms and stuff on your
campus theoretically ideally you'd have
conferences devoted to this
um you know with really good speakers
that know how to cross disciplinary
lines and know how to like think a
little bit higher level about what works
and what doesn't work in their field
like a kind of a what are those were the
survey papers but survey survey talks I
would love to see that about data like
data management and data analytics in a
given field and again I think workshops
for policymakers because the
policymakers are not actually bad people
they're just really busy and don't have
any details at all so the lobbyists tell
them what to think because that's what
lobbyists do but lobbyists are you
should think about it this way lobbyists
are performing a function that other
people could perform which is giving
them information that they want to hear
they'd love to hear information from
people who are academic and trustworthy
or they might not come themselves but
they'll send their aides and
congressman's aides are really smart I
think there's a huge need for
educational initiatives which a data
science institute would provide that
would be probably the easiest thing to
set up actually is setting up you know
masters and PhD programs at least the
very the first semester you could you
could hire some people to teach graduate
classes I actually think that this
concept of numerical and computational
literacy should be at the core of the
curriculum and for undergraduates the
stuff I did with my journalism students
this summer I could have done with
freshman at college and it would have
helped them it would have helped them in
a lot of ways so I don't see why 18 year
olds aren't doing that and I don't see
why data science institute wouldn't
wouldn't take the initiative on that it
would be a really popular popular class
I would expect I also think that you
know you heard me talk about this
interaction with the public that public
is at is a stakeholder here and i think
the stake that the sum of the public
really wants to understand this stuff
and where are they going to go for that
so it's not just about your
undergraduates although no this is a
very undergraduate
focused campus which is great I also
think that the general public should we
should have like information for the
general public on how you know what is
it what does Facebook actually know
about you and what are they allowed to
do with that that something you could
Google for but it would be a lot more
interesting and effective if we had like
really good speakers explaining that I
think the data science titude would
ideally provide resources to act the
academic researchers so this would be
another reason for them to want to be
part of it computing infrastructure we
talked a lot about today we have
basically ad hoc solutions to computing
problems in every department if not
every research lab and the question of
how to think about that in a more
holistic sense and like how to solve
that problem probably save money overall
I don't know how the actual funding
would work with that need a few staff to
organize the colloquium and the wine I
said you need space you need money I
mean ideally you'd have so um Columbia
started out with 50 million dollars
although that was all fake in various
ways I think in in the following sense
that they they didn't actually get any
money from Bloomberg they just got like
a decrease on their sewer taxes for like
15 years until it was worth 50 million
dollars or something so it's kind of a
weird situation but the point is that
you can hire people for the Institute
and you could do it one of two ways you
could hire people for the Institute like
you could hire a person be part of our
Institute or you could hire someone in
electrical engineering or in computer
science or in biometric bioinformatics
urch and then they'd be joint with the
Institute that's the model they use at
Columbia and then just for people who
are interested I also found out that
they when they have grants coming in
some percentage of it gets siphoned off
into the Institute so that's how it's
all about the money i know that i'm also
the way they do it in
it C is they have outside partners so
they they have like partnerships
contracts that they've now they've now
firmed up where they have like certain
things they offer larger companies like
IBM or GE or Accenture and they have
different kinds of contracts for
startups because startups want different
things than big companies do and they
also offer different things so big
companies offer money they want things
like expertise in a certain general area
and education in that area so they might
send some people from IBM to Columbia to
learn about this kind of filled it
startups want to take students to get
internships and they want to be able to
call someone up and ask them with very
specific machine learning question which
is a very different kind of ask anyway
so but establishing those kinds of
partners would be an important part of
an Institute for data science and you
know it's a different ecosystem in New
Haven than it is in New York City I
realize that but I think there are
partners it just might be more on the
side of policy or a different a
different industry than then exactly the
same thing in New York so this is where
I get to the part where I don't really
have opinions but i do think these are
important questions to ask so how would
you actually set this up like who would
even be included in this i mean from my
experience in journalism and data
science and mathematics i I'm getting
more and more to the point where I think
a broad definition as good like you do
want people from all sorts of
departments that are interested in this
now at the same time you probably don't
want to just get everyone in the room
and say hey what do we do you want to
have like some projects in mind or you
might have themes you might have liked
for these two years here's what we're
going to do like here's an idea for 43
years we're going to focus on people who
actually analyze the data and how do we
analyze the data how do we collect our
data and how do we manage our data and
then the next three years like we can
talk with people who don't analyze the
data but we they do interact with the
results of our analysis like not not the
medical researchers but the doctors who
use the results of our
analysis and that would be a different
project in the three years after that
you might want to interact with you want
to bring in people who are impacted by
your analysis because there's all sorts
of different ways of thinking about data
science and how it interacts with the
world and of course you could be
thoughtful and set up your data inside
its Institute to be itself data-driven
so you can see what works and what
doesn't and what is what inspires people
and what brings in grants and what
actually seems to in a long-term sense
create good research so a couple lessons
i got from chris wiggins before i left
any kind of and he's on the Executive
Board of it see he's also on the
education board and on the
entrepreneurial board so he set up
partnerships with on with the startups
any kind of mission that you create
mission attached to a data science
institute has to be novel I said there
has to be something you offer that you
don't see at Cornell the new Cornell
Tech or you NYU which also has a new
thing or it see it has to be coherent it
has to be doable I didn't write that
down but has to be doable and as and
there's an inverse relationship between
size and velocity so one of the reasons
at the end that it's he took three years
to start making progress because they
started out massive their first campaign
was to hire 75 faculty so that you know
it's if you try to do boil the ocean it
takes a while so I don't know what that
means it might all it means is you have
to be patient depending on how big you
want to be also obviously there has to
be a good incentive structure in place
as i think i might have said the funding
for it see went into the engineering
school and all the schools are siloed in
terms of their money so there's arts and
sciences there's the medical school and
yeah and they had to think pretty hard
about how to get medical researchers
interested in doing this and it's about
money and finally I just want to make
the point that well earlier from one of
the speakers we heard this idea that
that when the data from different fields
sits next to each other we will
we find connections I don't think that's
true going back to my original examples
people use different vocabulary even if
they've come to the same mathematical or
analytical approach they use different
words I was thinking once of building a
huge network of mathematics papers like
connected in directed graph like this
one was referenced by that one and this
is referenced by that one or maybe not
um just explicit references would be
even better if I just said topics these
are related because they have some of
the same using natural language
processing to say these are the related
to each other in topic and then I
realized that that wouldn't actually get
me where I wanted to go because what I
really want to go is I want to say one
or two methods to math papers related in
ideas that's not the same thing as words
and that's what we've learned is that
people who come at the same ideas but
they have totally different vocabulary
that's not going to happen through
machine learning algorithm that's only
going to happen through a community so
the connectors so L so no Emmy told me
that in the last three years she's she's
become the connector between the medical
school and the computer science
department she knows everyone there she
knows what they do and when someone
needs to know who can I talk to that
does this she knows who to go to them to
go to so unique connectors so I just
want to thank Chris Wiggins and noemi
for my interviewing them with annoying
questions and I'd love to take questions
thanks so let me introduce to you Steve
Gervin steve is the deputy provost for
science and technology as well as the
Eugene Higgins professor of physics and
applied physics his academic research is
in theoretical quantum physics his
portfolio includes a long list of things
including central campus science
departments the school of Forestry and
environmental studies School of
Engineering and Applied Sciences and
collaboration on science strategy with
the school of medicine and a good
partner for me and working in high
performing
computing Steve well thank you Kathy for
i'm making an interesting case for for
data science institute let me start by
saying i've met a large set of
mathematicians on a large set of people
persons and until today the intersection
was a null set so I'm pleased to pleased
to meet you so you've I mean I was
struck by sort of the one slide where
you use the word urgent about ethics
standards policy and complexity and and
perhaps universities are the last place
standing that can try to sit down and
think about some of these important
topics and in a way that's as unbiased
as possible it's certainly true that
we're the last bastion for basic
curiosity-driven research that has no
apparent like most basic research no
apparent applications and yet decade
after decade surprising applications do
appear often on a rather long timescale
inconsistent with corporate budgeting
and federal annual budgeting processes
and of course a place like yell that has
very strong humanities and 12
professional schools excellent law
school as you mentioned is a place that
can think about some of the implications
for the human race for some of these
amazing tools that the scientists and
engineers and entrepreneurs are creating
an unleashing honest
and I one of my hopes is that we can
find a way to to bridge the gap between
the humanities and the sciences and
engineering with the stupendous gap and
there we are programs and digital
humanities and some humanists beginning
to think about statistics of use of
words and different books and so forth
ancient texts and we have a computing in
the arts program but we still have a you
know a tremendous Gulf I mean when we we
had a Yale College faculty meeting about
grade inflation and an economist gave a
brilliant committee report saying that
you know when you have inflation
economics you've changed the currency
and so let's switch from a letter grade
system to a numerical grade system and
people won't be able to exactly map
between them and it'll be fine and and
the human humanists responded that I
don't treat my students as numbers so
that we have a we have a lot of work to
to get the whole Yale community
interested in statistics and numbers so
I think I had some slides but I don't
need to show them I my last slide a few
slides about the data that's pouring
into Yale brought to you by the evil
side of Moore's law namely the automated
machines that can generate the data
faster and faster in the huge telescopes
and the genome sequencing center that
does a human exilim every eight minutes
and so forth but we are my final slide
was on the topic sort of related to your
proposal here which is where we have
under discussion active discussion the
creation of a Yale center for research
computing or computational science which
could have a big overlap with the
proposal you're making and we have an
eye on some space and even as an
auditorium in it we're thinking about a
colloquium series and getting people
together to talk is and learn about each
other's research problems and finding
commonalities or stealing tricks that
people have learned from other fields is
an incredibly important activity in such
thing so I think I have more that bit of
commentary rather than questions for you
and let's let the audience ask the
questions thank you again
it's more this is more of a suggestion
than a question but it seems to me that
several people including Kathy have
commented on one of the ways to bring
multiple disciplines to the same table
and get them to start struggling with
communication is to have a junior
faculty member or a fellow who's trying
to do a project that's at the interface
between those two groups i would say
another way of doing that not competing
but a complementary way is to try to be
to have teams trying to solve a problem
together and comparing and contrasting
the approaches they might use from the
disciplines that they were trained in
because then all that language issue
begins to be quite apparent but also you
begin to understand how the mapping
works between those two different two or
three or four different disciplines so I
really I like you're going through all
the elements we need for data science
that's two here I thought that was
fantastic but one element I was thinking
about is one of the things we really
need for data science is we need data
and what data would we work on in this
data science institute I mean where
would that day to come from this you
know I hear all the time about all these
interesting things that Google and
Facebook are doing you know that all the
wizards on Wall Street are doing but I
don't know where to get that data and
you know I think where do we get data to
do interesting things in data science
well there's two ways of thinking about
that it's great question um one of them
is that the people who are involved in
your in your Center would already have
data because they already have projects
but another answer is I think you get it
from facebook no because I mean facebook
has a terrible PR problem right now
because they're so proprietary and
they're doing what relatively
questionable activities and I think if
you said you know about like a public
call for for examining certain things
about the way they act I think they
would probably give it to you because
they'd want to clear their name I mean I
think that's the kind of thing you
should do if you had an institute you
should be
challenging Facebook to show that
they're not doing something that's wrong
a library of data so to speak I mean and
also an understanding of where and how
one goes about getting that data whether
you're talking about EMR data or
Facebook data or means you learn from
each other about how to break through
the barriers I think I thank you i mean
i think the librarians here have already
explained that they they want to help
curate that library of data i also
wanted to mention that i didn't put into
my slide deck that um an institute like
this would not only give us a way of
collecting data but probably an
opportunity to build tools for research
that don't exist but should that would
promote the kind of collaboration that
would be useful in an institute so I'm
again that that's something that would
be novel I don't think that's happening
anywhere else I'm for the most part most
of the other Institute's that I know of
are in some sense like vehicles for NIH
and NSF grants but more than places
where they're actually building tools so
I like to say that I couldn't have done
my data journalism program without the
ipython notebook it's a tool which is
minimal it's it's got to get better it
will get better but it's a it's a great
tool and so it's the first step towards
something that we could make that's
really excellent that would make
research interactive and collaborative
you're just going to say in regards to
partnership with external organizations
I think that's key to really making such
a department a success because to your
earlier point you really need that
practical that real life data to analyze
to really understand how things will
work in the the real world so to speak
my backgrounders and baskets and
supermarket retail analytics and it's
very hard to practice sort of data
mining on those millions and billions of
rows of data without actually using the
actual basket data that has come from a
you know a retailer so I think having
those partnerships is really key to
it to making such a an enterprise a
success I'd like to throw in that if you
make the data science institute to some
extent kind of like a consultancy that's
what consultants do that's the model of
consultancy which is that you you get
paid to do jobs you don't own well the
question of IP should be separate but
you basically learn on the job how to do
certain things and and then you know how
to do them and then you can even build
your own product to solve that problem
once and for all once you've done this
is the same but in any case that's
another way you could learn not only
learn techniques but also get access to
data
I did want to throw in that I really
think that the law school is just such
an incredible resource because at the
very least we were talking last night
about the the medical records and I
think it was eben mo Glenn and his group
that sued to get the VA open sourced
like the VA system of medical
record-keeping open sourced and like I
mean so in other words lawyers are a
partner in in doing this the right way
and the very least to have them on your
side so you can threaten to sue if
people do something wrong or to get FOIA
requests which is afraid of Information
Act requests which is a trick I learned
in journalism school yeah the if you
were to have a data science institute
the thing I would want from them would
be I guess maybe the consultancy aspect
to be able to come in and say I have
data I need to know how to archive it
and curate it and make it accessible to
others can you people help me is that
I'm not sure I really saw that on your
slides is that part of what you see is
being the function of that kind of
Institute well certainly it's I'm some
basic education in that arena would be
part of the educational initiative I
mean part of it any education data
science would be that kind of thing but
in terms of whether there'd be actually
a service where you can I think that's
what the librarians already are but I
don't know that that's enough well but
they're going to up their game so it's
cool okay
I wrote I have a question on on the
potential for collaboration between
academics and Industry when it comes to
things like IRB especially you mentioned
the Facebook studies that have been very
controversial and something that I've
been thinking about is what if tech
industry set up its own IRB and it seems
like what you talked about some of the
unique things that Yale has when it
comes to interaction with policy makers
might allow it to influence or talk
about best practices in a way that you
know there's either a board that's set
up or just guidelines that are created
in this data science center so just to
get your thoughts about something like
that and what role you Yale could play
well I absolutely agree with you that
that's another great example of how it's
perfectly situated are for that kind of
thing the current state of course is
that people opt into the rules on
facebook or OkCupid and then there is no
I rb2 to board to pass the conversation
has like evolved recently because of the
I don't know if you guys have looked at
the okcupid data scientists book called
Datak lism he's gone on like NPR a bunch
of times like laughing in the face of
the concept of opting in he's like
nobody reads that nobody understands
that um he's you know playing a
dangerous game which I am enjoying
because I feel like at some point
policymakers are going to have to say
actually no one understands that nobody
reads that and it's insufficient maybe
that's but that's the conversation a
data science institute should hold with
the public and with policymakers that is
absolutely and by the way policymakers
can't hold that conversation by
themselves because they don't understand
data enough so I just wanted to say one
more thing is so first of all I was
really great that you mentioned the lis
p which is actually called the
information society program and really i
think is frankly thinking a lot about
these data science issues and I just I
wanted to
just follow up a little bit the question
I asked previously about where the day
is going to government what I see in
academia is there's this interesting
dynamic where there's a tremendous
amount of biological data and also data
from say astronomy Natural Sciences but
most of the driving force in data
science is the people in the commercial
world you know hiring these people in
the financial world or the retail world
advertising and so forth and whereas we
we can't actually study that data
because it's all locked up and
proprietary I was wondering if there's
some way of thinking about how to train
students on available natural sciences
data but sort of make them valuable for
that commercial work because it seems
that's what ends up happening I me I
think Phil Bourne kind of pointed this
out to with the Google bus type of thing
and how to think about that process well
you know I certainly think that the
education initiatives I always talked
about in my mind do that that they
fulfill the role of setting up students
to be useful for a job like Google and
having said that Google is like its own
universe and you know the statisticians
at Google don't even work with raw data
anymore because they have such an
amazing infrastructure they only use
higher-level languages like are so it's
kind of weird I mean and then you have
other things like startups that do
things like scrape the web and have
completely unstructured data I guess
what I'm saying is it's just so varied
its heart it would be hard to prepare
students for everything so but I do want
to just I guess it's a great moment to
go back to earlier today when I heard
something maybe was you talking about
stat of races are like I one of the
things that you do have to be you just
going to be scrappy when you work on
data science right so you just I learned
sequel over two days because that I
needed to do something with a sequel
database you just have to learn
everything and you have to just get used
to the fact that whatever you've gotten
really good at is going to be old hat in
a year which is one of the reasons like
when I see people talking about Hadoop
aduba dupe I'm like that's not that's
not what I'm going to be using next time
I get a job in industry I don't know
what it's going to be
it's going to be on the grid it's going
to have aspects of Hadoop it's going to
be parallel it's going to be fast it's
going to heat up the world's water but
it's not necessarily going to be call it
a dupe anymore excuse me my my
understanding is that and I have a
question on that for you so my
understanding is that the main problem
in data science in especially
specifically in academia is not neither
the data and not nor the algorithm so we
have frequent a lot of different very
good data sets and they can be used in
one or another way and we have a lot of
different algorithms and the real
potential of them remained mainly
untapped so I think the most important
problem is as you put it very well is a
kind of subject matter experts in
between of different domains and
disciplines like in medicine between
medical studies and computation and well
in computation between compute those do
computation and now about algorithms and
software engineers who can help to
create a building and a build up more
sophisticated and you know combined set
of algorithms instead of just a few line
of algorithm to do one task yeah so I'm
just going to get a really short pitch
from my book called doing data science
which just not because I get the
commission although I do but because it
the first chapter or two I think we
talked about building a data science
team and it's crucial in fact that you
don't first of all you don't think of it
as a project it's usually you're
building up a code base and you have
layers of models you know you're this
model will tell you whether they click
this one bottle will tell you whether
they buy this model will tell you
whether this other model will take those
two models and to decide whether they're
they're clicking and going away and not
coming back and buying you know that
kind of thing and in order to do that in
order to assemble a team you find people
who
are good at different things you have a
domain expert you have somebody who's
good at communicating with the business
people if someone who's good at
algorithms do someone who's good at
coding if someone is good at making it
fast if someone who's good at collecting
the data overnight that you need and so
it's a team effort in a way that I'm not
sure it's it's thought of the same way
in research but maybe it is in depending
on the field thank you guys